en même même en tentant pas un toc toc
voilà on si on sait qu'on sait on sait
que c'est mal prononcé donc à votre avis
c'est qui oui mais non c'est qu'alors
groupe et au toc toc toc qui et séguy
dickie qui met guillemets gamer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça tourne mal
mais
c'est rien ça il est bas ils novateur 39
il est batteur s'est produit à l'est le
chiendent tout va bien sûr tout va bien
il est 20h40
sarra belguith avoir un jardin
franchement ça passe regarde mon amour
je t'ai déjà je serai pas là ce soir
j'aurais adoré être là mais ce soir ça
n'est pas possible en tout cas je
voulais te dire que je t'aime très fort
et que c'est toujours un bonheur de se
réveiller à tes côtés de m voilà mon
petit soleil donc ta petite à des thèmes
très fort et puis et puis rendre vite
[Applaudissements]
c'est beau de merde la musique mais
c'est beau cette cvo je suis un garçon
très heureux il y aurait pour nom benji
pas par sms parce qu'on n'a pas voilà
c'est pourquoi je suis très ému et
au second
autour d'une chope
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais vraiment qu'ils se mettent aux
nues moi je rajoute 500 morts tu vas
leur cave alors ça me dit
k
[Applaudissements]
regardez moi
doux
[Applaudissements]
allez tape attaqué à sept-îles il skie
et venaient boire
[Musique]
dans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
g
et
il m'a serré la main ce qu'on a du coup
j'ai pas les marques sol c'est ça ouais
depuis tout à l'heure je suis vous les
mettez à l'elysée où plaît mettez vous
là bas ça va très bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]